why are we in Syria why do we have
troops in Syria uh and what authorizes
troops to be in Syria and Iraq at this
point that is a foundational question
and it's weird you know the Republicans
aren't asking that question now but they
will you know when it becomes
politically advantageous what Iran is
doing in the region is trying to
destabilize any kind of either you know
actual Accords or growing Accords
between places like Israel and UAE and
Israel and Saudi Arabia America
shouldn't have troops there America if
they want Regional stability it would
have been nice not to have spent a
couple of decades destroying Iraq which
was the uh you know the regional uh
opponent and Nemesis of Iran and held
them in check obviously all we did was
destroy that country so that Iran can
have a a bigger hand but we should be
spending all of our diplomatic efforts
right now trying to build up a regional
Coalition of countries that all
hate Iran